the Senate's top Democrat has changed
his mind about paying for a wall along
Mexico's border Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer offered to go along with
president Trump's demand less than a
week ago
well now Schumer says the wall is off
the table the president responded on
Twitter last night saying if there is no
wall there is no daca Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning so Schumer argues that the
president scuttled that deal that they
were crafting so he's scuttling his
offer and now that the two sides are
embarking on new negotiations here on
Capitol Hill but it's also true that
Democratic political considerations have
changed last week they were trying to
show that they were bending over
backwards to try to avert a shutdown and
so they let it be known that Schumer was
willing to meet the president's full
requests for border wall funding about
twenty five billion dollars in exchange
for legal protection for immigrants
brought to this country illegally as
children but now they are taking a
tougher stance to try to pacify a
furious
liberal base activists who say Democrats
caved on government funding for nothing
more than a promise from the GOP leader
to hold a vote on dreamers next month
congressional negotiators now have just
15 days to cut a dreamer dreamer deal
and Republicans say Schumer's backtrack
is going to slow things down Democrats
argue John that Republicans have been
slow walking these talks for months
thanks Nancy